[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
it is never too late to get to the truth
the daughter of a man executed for
murder
is calling for new dna testing in his
case but prosecutors say
it shouldn't be allowed at some point
this must end
should riders in the deadly capital
insurrection be accused of organized
crime
or experts weigh in on possible new
charges there is no way
that the proud boys and the three
percenters and those other
organizations operated in a vacuum plus
the police interrogation of the woman
charged with helping to cover up the
murder of a mother of five
michelle tracona says she's innocent in
the death of jennifer doulos
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a tennessee woman is asking the state's
highest court to test evidence
she says could clear her father's name
but that raises a new question
should dna testing be allowed in a case
after a defendant is executed
it's very overwhelming
i feel like i'm being pulled in a
thousand different directions
that was april alley in 2019 after she
first petitioned the state to retest
evidence in her father's case
ali was just nine years old when her
father sadly ali was arrested
later convicted and then executed in
2006.
watching my father died was so painful
that i'm hoping i can get the answer
one way or the other that i want
ali believes her father could be the
first person proven innocent by dna
testing
after their execution sadly ali was
found guilty of the rape and murder
of marine lands corporal suzanne marie
collins in 1985.
police say collins was out jogging when
she was abducted tortured
raped and left for dead two marines
pointed out aly's car as the suspect's
vehicle
and he even confessed to the crime but
attorneys with the innocence project say
his story doesn't line up with the
evidence
and offer another possible suspect we
had an investigator we hired a private
investigator who went out
she discovered that suzanne collins had
a boyfriend
in memphis and a fiancee in california
and the boyfriend in memphis didn't know
about that beyonce in california
but she was getting ready to end that
relationship in memphis
to go back to the boyfriend that
boyfriend
drove the exact same wood paneled
station wagon that was described as the
vehicle
that abducted suzanne collins and he
matched the description of the person
who abducted
suzanne collins the innocence project
wants a pair of underpants worn by the
attacker
as well as the victim's bra and socks
tested for dna
the items are sitting at evidence in a
clerk's office prosecutors however say
allie had enough time to appeal his case
when he was still alive twice
post-conviction courts
uh took up his petitions and they gave
it a full analysis and they said he did
not meet the four statutory factors
twice this court looked at that gave
full decisions
uh full and and thorough decisions about
why that those decisions should be
affirmed uh
twice the tennessee supreme court looked
at that uh
and declined to declined review from a
rule 11 application
twice the u.s supreme court reviewed the
petitions for rid of cert
that were filed about this and twice
declined to uh grant review
so there was a full uh full opportunity
multiple full opportunities i it to
suddenly alley
to for regarding dna testing
and due process does not compel this
court to say
well he should have yet another one
lawyers for the innocence project made
their arguments for post-conviction
relief
on behalf of the defendant's estate
the state argues that its own actions in
executing a convicted defendant
extinguished not only a life but any
claim for access to evidence
in the state's exclusive possession that
might demonstrate that the state has
executed the wrong person
that cannot be right if the state had
adopted a policy
of automatically destroying all dna
evidence concerning a crime
including trial exhibits that would
otherwise be kept indefinitely
immediately after an ex execution it
would be an obvious injustice and due
process violation
but if the state cannot destroy evidence
just because it's executed the defendant
then it makes no more sense to be for
the state to be able to cut off
access to the same evidence just because
they've executed an individual
joining us is law and crime host
attorney and expert on cases like this
linda kenny baden along with defense
attorneys imran ansari and terry austin
linda you've been passionately following
this case
what should we be focusing on here okay
so let's remember this this case was in
1985 that this defendant was convicted
the person was now seeking dna through
his daughter through the estate right
there wasn't even dna that was used in
the courtroom anywhere in the usa
at that point so there was no
opportunity to use dna then
when the chance came later in the 1990s
to use dna
the courts in tennessee said you mr
suddenly ali you can't get it you know
why
and let me read it to you because it's
mind-blowing that there's not a
reasonable probability
that you wouldn't have been prosecuted
or convicted if the tests were in your
favor
okay so that was the nod then later on
when he sought again dna testing uh in
2006
2004 he was executed 2006 the court said
well you can't put it into the codis
database so we can't give you dna
testing
so what the state is basically arguing
is that because
we screwed up along the way you are now
not a person because you're dead
under the dna testing statute to get dna
and that's where this case lie today
and that's where these judges on the
appellate courts
are deciding whether or not suddenly
ali's estate through his daughter is a
person to get dna
tested testing now i mean imran
especially taking that information what
do you make of the prosecution's
argument
that uh ali's time to appeal has come
and gone
yeah brian you know the prosecution is
really taking a stance on a procedural
ground in terms of arguing that this
appeal process
is not appropriate at this time you
heard the prosecutor going through all
the attempts
to get this reviewed before an appellate
court he talked about
ri being denied that's me that means
that the appellate court
uh that specific appellate court are
denied to review
uh this conviction and you know they're
really hanging their hat
on this procedural argument saying the
time has passed
procedurally and all the appellate uh
opportunities to get appellate review
have been exhausted
and that's why this one should be denied
all right tara you listen to the
arguments on the appeal how do you think
the court
would rule here well i hope the court
should rule in favor of ali and here's
why
this is a person whether the person has
passed away or not
and the real public interest reason why
the court should rule in favor of ali
is the fact that with this new dna
evidence
we can find out who the real killer
might be
all right we'll see if this dna evidence
does get tested and we can figure out
who the real killer is thank you all for
your input still ahead on law and crime
daily
a former police officer charged with
murdering a man in ohio makes his first
court appearance
plus what new charges federal
prosecutors are considering
for riders in the siege of the capitol
building stick with us for continuing
coverage
[Music]
a former ohio police officer charged
with murdering a man pleads not guilty
as the judge sets his bail at 3 million
adam coy appeared via video from jail he
faces charges of murder
felonious assault and dereliction of
duty for the death of andre hill
coy is accused of shooting hill in
columbus last december while responding
to a non-emergency call
hill was in his friend's garage at the
time coy's attorneys say he thought hill
was armed with a gun
but he actually was holding a set of
keys
the feds have arrested more people this
week for the attack on the u.s capitol
law and crimes anjanet levy is here with
more on my home country's labeling
of this group involved
canada has declared the proud boys a
nationalist group a domestic terrorist
organization
as another member here in the united
states faces charges for the capital
riot
nearly a month after rioters stormed the
u.s capitol
federal agents are arresting more people
on serious charges
the u.s attorney's office and maine
justice
are now focusing on the broader contours
of january 6 in the attack on the
capital
as well as the events that occurred way
before
january 6 and also events after
jean rossi is a former assistant u.s
attorney peter schwartz of pennsylvania
faces a list of charges agents included
photos of a man they say is schwartz
spraying an orange substance at police
officers ethan nordin of washington
state
faces several charges including aiding
and abetting injury or depredation
against government property
nordine also goes by rufio panman and
screen grabs show him appearing on the
conspiracy theory website
infowars he is a member of the proud
boys
the proud boys is an organization it's
an enterprise that could be
charged under the rico statute and its
whole goal basically is this
they hate everybody but themselves the
leader of the proud boys
told sky news there will be more
violence if the group's demands are not
heard
and rossi believes the group may have
been assisted by the trump campaign
which could mean criminal charges for
those involved including the former
president
if the evidence is there the people who
stormed the capital were puppets
and they were puppets of a person named
president donald trump
also this week so-called q anon shaman
jacob chansley was moved to a jail in
alexandria
after claiming he lost 20 pounds after
not being fed organic food
at another facility i gotta give his
attorney credit
that took a lot of guts to file a motion
with a federal court
judge in d.c and say my client's rights
are being violated
because he's not getting organic food
and gene rossi believes that federal
grand jury investigation
could take at least a year for law and
crime daily i'm angenette levy
thanks ange back for analysis our
lawyers imran ansari and terry austin
imran racketeering influence and
corruption organization what does rico
charges mean for those proud boys
charge and how strong are the
government's claims
sure well brian you know the government
would have to make sure that they have a
pretty
airtight solid case in order to make out
the ricoh charge rico charges uh
are very um stringent in terms of the
elements
that are needed to be proven by the
prosecution in order to hold
a ricoh charge they would have to prove
that the proud boys
were a criminal enterprise and that
there was a pattern of predicate
criminal acts
to constitute a rico charge they would
have to show that
at least two or more other incidents
asides from the capital
riot um were criminal and they were part
of this sort of criminal enterprise of
the proud boys
and it's going to be a real uh you know
the government's really going to have to
do their homework
they're going to have to have the
evidence because rico charges when you
bring them
often face a motion to dismiss so they
need to have the right evidence
now terry with canada labeling the proud
boys domestic terrorists
does that bring any pressure on america
to do the same or do you think they
should be
labeled the same way here in america
you know brian i think your home country
canada is leading the way here and it
will have some influence on the united
states jen paske just literally at a
press conference said
they are considering whether or not they
should label proud boys
as terrorists and so these groups are
active around the world and i think that
we have to make a concerted effort to
make sure that we quell their activities
and naming them
as a terrorist group will help do that
because you can't associate
with a terrorist group rico capital
insurrections and now
a potential labeling domestic terrorist
group will make sure to keep eyes
on the capital riot arrest thank you
both coming up on law on crime daily the
scary message sent out over a state
alert system
plus a wild robbery caught on camera how
thieves apparently made away with
thousands into stolen goods
the video you don't want to miss next
welcome back let's check in on some of
the top true crime stories of the day
terry austin has the latest on alleged
thieves trying to make off with a big
hull
brian police say gunmen forced their way
into the chanel store in manhattan and
stole
thousands of dollars worth of designer
goods nypd detectives
released surveillance video showing a
group of people
breaking into the store the thieves
ransacked the shop
grabbing 12 wallets and 32 handbags
worth
160 thousand dollars the store's
security guard
reportedly confronted one of the men who
claimed to be
armed saying she too was armed police
say
the thief responded saying what are you
going to do
shoot me they made a way with the loot
into a waiting vehicle
police believe the same suspects are
responsible for burglaries in at least
20 high-end retail stores throughout
manhattan
and in texas authorities are apologizing
after an
amber alert describing the suspect as
the chucky doll was mistakenly sent out
the message read abducted child glenn
age 5 years old
suspect chucky aged 28 years old wearing
denim overalls
wielding a huge kitchen knife his race
was listed under
other as doll it was of course a
reference to the horror film featuring
the infamous evil doll the texas
department of public safety said the
alert was a test malfunction
terry as a child of the 80s texas had
scared me for just a moment i was like
are we sure this is a joke
what did you make of this doll-sized
mix-up
you know what brian i want to know whose
idea
was this why couldn't they just say jane
doe
why did they have to use such a horrible
image i think it probably
scared a whole lot of people not just
you
yeah jane doan we can also probably
remove chucky altogether as well
and in florida one suspect was hoping
his flattery would help him get a lower
bond with a judge
imran listen to this next clip and let
me know if you'd recommend this strategy
for one of your clients
so that brings us uh to mr
demetrius lewis on page 26
how you doing how you doing all right
i'm good sir how are you
george you is so gorgeous i just have to
tell you
you're gorgeous thank you mr lewis all
right
all right mr lewis vladimir will get you
everywhere but maybe not here
the the court finds probable cause on
count one burglary occupied dwelling
unarmed count two possession of mdma
ecstasy
uh the court is going to set bond uh
based on the priors in this case
uh as his priors and the facts of this
case the court is gonna step on at five
thousand dollars on count one
the court will ror mr lewis on count two
i mean imran for the record the
prosecutor asked for 75 000 the judge
set
five thousand so maybe it worked what do
you think
yeah brian maybe it worked you know and
knocked off 70k off that uh
that uh bail so uh would i recommend
that to my client well you know i would
say know your judge there's some judges
who would take
uh offense to that sort of conduct and
that arguable
uh you know disrespect in court but then
there's judges like
judge blackman here i think she saw
she's a little lighthearted she saw the
the humor in it all i think she was a
little flattered and who knows maybe it
worked for this defendant
and uh you know he's at what 5k bale
instead of 70. now imran
i want to ask you which judges you can
do this in brooklyn but we've got we've
got to head out real quickly so i guess
we can't find that out
but uh thanks for the input there when
we come back
we take you inside the police
interrogation room as detectives press
michelle troconis
on the disappearance of jennifer doulos
the missing mother still never found
a wisconsin man is serving life in
prison for a double murder and
kidnapping
law and crimes jessie weber digs into
how a young girl was able to free
herself
on his new show prime crime
thanks brian coming up on prime crime
we're going back to the abduction of
jamie closs this was the girl who was
taken from her home after her parents
were brutally
and viciously murdered right in front of
her we'll start with the police body cam
and dash cam tapes as officers responded
to the crime scene
and then we're going to get into the
dramatic 9-1-1 phone calls including one
that took place
during the attack
and since we just passed the two-year
anniversary from the conclusion of this
kidnapping
we take a look at what happened and
what's next
tune in to law and crime
attorneys for a woman accused of helping
her now deceased boyfriend
clean up a murder want her charges
dismissed michelle troconis is facing
charges of conspiracy to commit murder
and evidence tampering in the
disappearance of jennifer doulos
dulos was reported missing in may 2019
and her body has never been found
police became suspicious and then
arrested her husband photos doulos
along with his girlfriend michelle
trucones and friend kent mahini
photos dulos died a year ago of an
apparent suicide truconis lawyers say
evidence proves
police lie to obtain warrants and
release this clip of her interrogation
like i said the defense released part of
the interrogation to show quote
falsehoods reckless disregard of the
truth and omitted material facts
in order to get the case dismissed how
does the video help their argument
though
yeah brian i think the video does help
their argument when you juxtapose it on
what was
uh in the materials that were used by
law enforcement to effectuate the arrest
uh and the basis of the warrant so
anytime there's a contradiction
uh between the information in those
paperwork
and that paperwork and what we're seeing
in the video and other material that the
defense is putting before the court
that really will support their argument
and i think this video
um does raise some questions now terry
they released this to the public this
wasn't done
uh in front of a jury so do you think it
was a smart move releasing the video
uh to get this case dismissed i do i
mean i think releasing it to the public
is really going to affect what the
public is thinking about this case first
of all you
see her and throughout the entire video
she's crying and some people might look
at that
and say she's being very sincere the
other issue is
over and over she's repeating the fact i
didn't do it i didn't do it so i think
her testimony here is very consistent
and ultimately if it is something that
the jury sees
i think they're going to look at her as
somewhat sympathetic
and i do think actually it was probably
a smart move
imran really quickly could this be a way
the defense is trying to
i don't know like i don't want to say
taint the potential jury pool but maybe
influence the potential jury pull a
little to say hey
have some sympathy for her absolutely
you know and that's also uh always a
consideration in a high profile case
how it plays out in the court of law but
equally as important most of the time is
how it plays out in the court of public
opinion
and i think the defense had that in mind
all right so maybe they're playing
both in the actual court in the court of
public opinion makes sense
imran terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here at law on
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you